[Applause]
so this really isn't about me or my work
this is really about a really
extraordinary panel has been assembled
I'm just going to take a couple minutes
to kind of frame it a little bit around
this notion of programmability and
material world I started with Franklin
started a company in 2003 that we call
the area code it'd be cool if other
people could see the slide that I can
see and I could describe it but I feel
certain that that's less interesting
then anyway we did anybody look yep
okay anyway let's see
so speaking of programmable environment
so okay so we we started this company in
2003 called
called area code and what we were
interested in was this was this notion
that there were the physical things the
area and code everything that was
digital everything in the cloud and that
anything that was actually interesting
or relevant in the world was actually
somewhere down the middle and so we then
we were specifically focused around
games and so as you can see in this
slide here this is the types of
experiences that we were interested in
were how to bring sort of invisible
factors into the world in some way and
so this is a game that we did where
people are actually being pursued down
the street by something invisible and
sort of is back in 2003 2004 about 13
years before Pokemon go a couple billion
dollars before Pokemon go the idea that
there were things that could have
without having a physical presence could
have meaning in physical space and that
that would be a material that we could
somehow play with and
okay I'll start over now okay anyway
well so we were inspired by stuff like
this right so this is this was the
situation its ideas of psychogeography
and the idea that that somehow maybe the
ideas that were that were sort of
propagating in the 50s and 60s around
the qualities of space cycle
geographically could be somehow
instantiated in terms of software that
they didn't they didn't just have to
become ideas this was the game from 2004
this is what it looks like when people
are running down the street being
pursued by something invisible in my
time at the Media Lab I've gotten
increasingly interested in actual real
things that are invisible and so there's
been a series of collaborations with the
Moore building company the real things
that are invisible basically all of the
basic the the vast microbiological world
that's around you inside you and
actually usually somewhere in between
the two the work that I've been doing
for the last little while is sort of
much more focused on that on the
invisible worlds that we are actually
surrounded by you have to do different
kinds of things if you're going to
engage with that that's not just a
question of programming a phone you need
to somehow be able to engage with that
invisible life and that invisible
material we've been using bees to
collect that material for us and then
sequencing what they bring back for us
that looks more like this and using that
basically to make exhibitions this was
at the Venice architecture Biennale last
year and this idea that underneath all
of it is just the the the conviction
that there is something far more
valuable and and meaningful and in the
invisible and the beauty can be mined
from there somehow and the only other
thing I'm going to use to kind of frame
this up is is this guy Cedric price who
when I studied in Frankfurt in the early
90s he was hanging out there among other
things that he was doing and you know
best known for the 1964 fun palace and I
mention it because I feel like the fun
palace
has somehow touched I would say probably
everybody's work here in some way
without ever actually getting built and
that's that that's what ideas can do but
it's something that people keep trying
to build this idea of a building that
can become whatever it needs to become
and it was instantiated by Richard
Rogers a tile in the pump you do this is
the I would say the latest version
setting out to to bring it to life this
is the shed which is being built in New
York City this will be ready in April 20
19 so this is that's roughly the city
block there and it's a five-story
exhibition space and what is this is a
Diller Scofidio and Renfro Liz Diller
that's the High Line coming up there
what's what is different about this
building from all other buildings is
that this is the building that actually
moves so that's a that's a cage that's
effectively over that that that can
extend out to become a performance space
for a couple thousand people or not and
then it has the kind of extreme
flexibility within it that Cedric price
imagined but wasn't really possible
until right around now and I think you
know when you start to see what's
possible this is 2019 it's been under
construction for a while has a lot
longer to go you can start to imagine
being able to have this level of
flexibility across all scales I I
include this this is the Hertzog and
emraan arena in in in Munich which you
know the problem there is that you
couldn't build they couldn't build an
arena for both of the different football
teams that were there so they built one
that could actually just do that and let
you know which team was playing and and
I wrote this is like 2003 2004 and I
remember at the time thinking wow that's
really legitimately provocative right
it's a building that can change its skin
to to somehow suggest or communicate
what's actually happening inside and but
looking back on it whatever it is like
13 years later I think it's provocative
precisely because it's such a
superficial aspect of the building right
it's just the skin and that that's in
fact
sort of the least interesting aspect of
what a building is and does and just to
Levon or set it up really with this
quote so this is Levin Manovich she was
writing right around the same time this
very 2003-2004 around exploits water
pavilion and this has always stayed with
me I've always thought about this quote
that the water pavilion is continuously
changing services illustrate the key
effect of a computer revolution the
substitution of every constant by a
variable and I have always thought about
this like that yeah that that's the core
of it right like that's the core of the
question that this is this is what
changes when people who are used to
computers start to look at things that
are physical that are material that are
somehow embodied in the world but also
lately I've been thinking the thing
that's actually really interesting to me
about this idea is that we ever aspired
to constants that that that was somehow
the premise that we would make things
that don't change that lasts forever and
that that just seems if you look back on
it historically ideological I kind of a
weird idea or maybe it starts to and
with that I want to bring on their first
panelists which i think is Casey I don't
actually it's Casey right yeah it's
Casey
and and get out of the way